today we are playing hide and seek for a
ten thousand dollar fridge
they can hide all across the planet
server dropped the gate
oh my gosh i gotta go hide oh
god uh they can hide in america
asia europe africa wherever they want
it's the statue of liberty look at that
it's so beautiful i'm going to japan
what if i just follow spiffy the entire
time this is literally terrifying we
have to check the entire planet how are
we gonna find them that's gonna take
forever
this is my hiding spot right here
probably not that clutch
this is perfect there's no way
wait this might be very good yo nice
spot dude i'm making a grass skin
oh that's so clever yes this will win
this will win this this team is op
if i just go like this this is see this
seems really good do i find the best
spot i'm between two trees
oh is this good okay in japan let's go
we're hiding right here for now
all right i'm in my spot it's not very
good please don't
say anything ten nine skip a feud one
let's go well they're going
oh my god they're speeding to us they're
heading to europe they're heading to
europe we're good
it's not every day you just get to
destroy the eiffel tower
take that france tecto is
anyone in antarctica how many fridges
are you willing to pay me for this
information
i'll throw in a 5 000 fridge if you win
yo
double fridge yeah there's no one there
there's no one there at all
oh my god oh my god chris you just found
me oh did i i was just telling that
chandler i don't know
i suck you're in this area no
yeah let's go bomb the area
what you have bombs yeah baby oh chris
you'll never find me
i saw you you
you cheater are you dead yet no wait did
you oh
die die die you're not getting the
fridge you're stuck with your moldy
fridge
baby you just blew me up
[Music]
you guys want to sell some people out
for me russia is kind of stacked
i guess i'm pillaging russia on my own
let's see is anyone in this building
this is kind of terrifying wait can you
hear my snowballs oh my god you got me
wait i killed you yep totally oh it just
popped up on my chat you were in that
building
yeah i was i'm quitting
i'm quitting we are now at the giant
fridge in the middle of antarctica
help me it's freezing and chandler you
were the first person to die so i
screwed myself so
got some word on the street fundies in
canada
uh i heard new zealand streets popping
that's just a straight up lie actually i
don't know why you would believe him
let's just see if new zealand's popping
off right now jimmy if i don't get the
freeze no i'm done
this is australia let's just blow up the
opera thing just to check
where's new zealand is this new zealand
what does this sign say something
lord of the rings related so this has
got to be new zealand or
is new zealand above it where is new
zealand
oh he passed right over me oh my god
chandler i lived
all right i just realized you guys could
see where me and chris are on your maps
that's not very fair
in five minutes we're gonna just
completely delete asia
off the map wait wait what oh god oh my
god
good thing i was never hiding there i've
been in canada with fundy the whole time
i'm going to canada oh boy oh boy
oh no
no oh hey wildcat what's going on man
i'm a migrant pig i'm migrating oh no
they're so close okay this okay guys
all right that's cool that's fine no
fridge for wildcats
[Music]
should have gone there oh what'd you see
chris i think you missed something down
here
oh wait wait wait wait wait give me a
second here i wanna i have a cool trick
that i can show you
guys all right clean your case so
basically what i'd like sage
you'll never catch me alive
wait this is awkward
i'm trying to negotiate with you get on
top of this stupid boat negotiations
okay
currently two of the 10 people have been
found we could kill you right now
or you could rat out two people and we
let you go scot-free
are you willing to sacrifice two people
so you stay in yo can i get an extra
boat as well
here we'll give you one extra boat tell
us where two people are right now
or we're gonna kill you i see just verb
and spiffy
up there where's up there here you tell
us where if we're going the right
direction chris come with me
okay mr beast is pretty much going the
right way i'm not gonna lie i feel like
they were hiding in a building we
already blew up
oh oh oh oh no it's chris act like you
don't see him act like you don't see him
i bet you he's freaking out right now
oh no oh no i'm gonna jump down in front
of him let's see what he does
oh my god he doesn't think we see him
chris watch it
360.
i thought he didn't see me
are we confident techno couldn't escape
from that prison yeah we should probably
check actually he's really good at stuff
like that come on
have a little bit of faith how'd you get
out you don't have blocks
is he out what i i just jumped and
placed the boat outside and then got in
the boat outside
chris i was just being nice i'm sorry
i'm a nice guy
there are now three prisoners he can row
a boat uh
attention everybody i wanted to let you
know that the prisoners are now gonna
help me find a few people don't worry
one of them's chandler so there's really
only two prisoners helping uh no hard
feelings just verb about uh earlier
all right fundy same plan we got this
chris and chandler i'm deploying you to
the north america
wildcat and verb i'm deploying you guys
to africa i'm gonna go hunt europe okay
chandler let's go this way
oh god they're all flying oh my god on
the move they're on the move they're on
the move they can all fly
oh god feels like they're breathing down
on x it's worrying
[Music]
yeah i really don't think there's
anybody here oh god they're destroying
africa
we can move but i think we have an
obligation to like come back at some
point you know i should probably move
now
i'm a gamer i got to go freaking fast
though enemy i see 130 above
no small hat what happened
i have one in the end you fell right
into our trap mr smalling you wanted to
ride out one of your comrades
there's someone in alaska that's all
i'll say in alaska okay
and now they go and find a rambu and now
that half the people have been found
this is a perfect time to shrink the
border again so the borders are now
shrinking to north and south america
i had to travel right away from japan
and i made it all the way here
gentlemen i want you guys to put your
trihard pants on and take some fridges
from people
all right there we go i got my trihard
pants on and this is carl
hi and i really have to poop so carl
take over for 10 minutes hello
it's me jimmy hey jimmy you got shorter
you can't even tell
it's a face camp oh
i just heard nukes yeah they're nuking
welcome to
america are there any holes an a hollow
tree perhaps
maybe like uh maybe like underneath a
birch tree run
run ramboo my plot armor
go go go snowball snowball snowballs
snowballs
oh he's going oh he's [ __ ] it get out
of there
go go no i snowballed you so hard ranbu
i definitely wasn't next to ranboo you
know what rainbow you get a 500
taco bell gift card cause i'm mr beast
rambu if you give us the location of
somebody i'll make sure you get a fridge
uh california i really hope they find
them i really want this fridge
oh no oh wait i found him no chris
spiffy no spiffy spiffy he's so close to
me
please
bye they got him i got a fridge spiffy
almost killed me but i'm still here oh
my god do they see me
hey mr beast i just promised rambo a
fridge wait so do i get both the fridge
and the taco bell gift card
i guess so because mr beast can't lie
[Music]
that was a good poop yes this border is
getting kind of small this pretty is
kind of getting small i'm kind of scared
where are you no more trees
techno definitely is a tryhard so he
probably changed his skin to blend in
oh who's that there's no one
no no mr puns i'll spare you if you sell
out someone
right at the center of the border you're
going to find some people
nice nice thank you i lied about sparing
you
all right three remaining wait wait is
this all right guys i'll make a deal
with you if i tell you where i am i get
five thousand dollars
yeah i bet you will if i get five
thousand dollars i'll tell you where
technoblade is
lead us to techno right now i already
know where he is
wait wait wait wait wait i was right
here fundy's on the top left right now
you guys should go after him where
oh techno is down to remain oh
god he's gone oh all right
i got him that is funny he's the
i'm a winner block baby this is the
person
that just won a 10 000
fruit yes boo
you have five seconds fundy what do you
have to say ha